talk about circuits okay thanks
we're coming thanks organizers for
inviting me the organizers asked me to
speak about my work with others on
threshold circuit lower bounce from a
couple of years ago so this is not brand
new work but there are several
interesting tools that I think are worth
like focusing on and bringing up again
for the purpose of this semester
well I'll warn you this is to one our
talks compressed in the 30 minutes we'll
see how it goes I think so yeah as I
said this talk is that kind of a zombie
merger of two previous talks
okay so warning the first talk or part
is on suply superlinear gate and super
quadratic wire lower bounds against
depth 3tc zero for computing some
explicit function so this is majority of
majorities of majorities this is work
with Daniel Caine that appeared in stock
2016 it uses random restrictions so it
uses a very classical way of thinking
about lower bounds in terms of randomly
restricting the inputs so in that part
the slides have a black background in
the second half of the talk we will
switch backgrounds and will prove some
somewhat larger gate lower bounds
against a threshold of threshold so so
depth to but arbitrary weights as
opposed to DEP 3 which Tsz roads
majority of majority majorities for a
not so explicit function so it's
computable in time to the order n within
NP Oracle but it does use totally
different techniques it get some
satisfiability algorithms in order to
prove the lower bounds it uses
probabilistic polynomials in a crucial
way and I do want to point out that sue
Tamaki shows similar but slightly weaker
results in than what I will say also
using politic polynomials with a
different construction
and at the end I'll talk about open
problems so because of this switch
between black and white background I
feel obligated to tell you that it is
not known to the state of California and
watching this talk is helpful for your
vision okay believe I have believe I
have legally covered myself very good
let's go
so I want to start by just recalling
what is the linear threshold function
it's sort of the key object of this talk
so it's a boolean function taking in
inputs giving one output and so it's
implemented by real-valued weights one
for each of the inputs in the threshold
weight T and so that for all boolean
inputs this function outputs one if and
only if the sum of over all I of WI X of
I is at least T it's some linear form is
at least a threshold value hey you know
what's powerful here will be the weights
okay it sort of leads to the the current
barrier and lower bounce so just think
of it as some kind of thing that takes
in in bits and outputs a bit and is
checking this condition in the middle
okay
so this these things have a very long
history so called perceptrons studied
many decades ago this talk will be
talking about depth three and depth two
circuits where you get two so this is
called multi-layer perceptrons one
hidden layer but for the rest of us it's
a linear threshold whose inputs are the
outputs of other linear thresholds it's
for this talk all the usual notation I
guess nowadays is threshold of threshold
is how you say that
okay and it looks something like this
okay there's that single output gate
giving the boolean value and there is
taking input from some middle gates okay
this is the so-called hidden layer these
middle gates
this is computing some boolean function
so just a very short history of things
here so so every function so you know
it's computable by a threshold threshold
but it could have exponentially many
gates or wires it's not hard to
to see this so one question is which
functions so thought of as if the
families of boolean functions have a
threshold threshold family with pong
little mini gates okay which in which
you not okay this question is largely
unanswered really like you think about
explicit functions functions in P or an
NP we really don't know very much in
fact the question was open for our
linear number of gates okay as we'll see
but there has been some progress on this
and this is what Daniel and I were
looking at so in poly also patear Ian
Sachs showed that patear the parity of n
bits needs into the one point five wires
at least and this is tie in the average
case you can exhibit to something that
has order this many wires on the average
it was also shown that inner product mod
two in bit vectors needs at least a
linear number of gates bye Rach honoree
whisky ensue and if the weights and one
layer are restricted to say like minus
one zero one either the top or the
bottom
there are exponential lower bounds no in
fact even the recent work of our cadaver
nickel Monday shows that there are
functions in threshold a threshold that
cannot be computed by so-called
thresholds of majorities okay this was
actually an open question so this is
so-called p c0 depth to lower balance if
they meet threshold of majority is
majority of thresholds and so on you saw
talks about these things yesterday okay
so it was open weather say a huge
classic e to the NP had special special
of linear the number of gates and
slightly more than one point six wires
something like this are even majority
majority circuits of similar parameters
and so what we showed was some of our
bounds for explicit function so first
off there is an eight so that it's
computer Impala no time in fact it is in
TC 0 DEP 3 with linear number of gates
okay and it has depth to thresholds with
cubic nor gates but we can prove
a decent polynomial lower bound so it
doesn't have threshold thresholds in the
1.5 roughly gates nor within the 2.5
wives
divided by some poly log factor so
there's still a gap kind of what is the
threshold threshold complexity of this
function but the main thing is that this
is nonlinear and this is super quadratic
it holds even for some sort of average
case the next theorem we show it holds
for four depth 3tc zero so a majority of
threshold threshold in fact so we show
there's a function that's computable in
NC probably in TC 0 I didn't actually
check there I guess but it we can show
it doesn't have majority of threshold of
threshold circuits of roughly similar
parameters so we get to have a thorough
majority on top of this function here ok
so the first theorem one is proved using
a function that is used in the boolean
formula where bounds called ondrea's
function which I'll review theorem two
uses some modified on jus function which
sort of applies the error correcting
code to one half of the input which I
will not talk about I just but I will
talk a bit about the theorem one so just
to review on J's function so it uses
this thing called a K bit multiplexer
which takes to the K inputs and along
with a extra K bit string and use the K
bit string to index into the longer to
the case string sort of casting this bit
string as an integer and then I'll like
say I and then outputting X at Y okay
then andreas function on to the K + to
the K bits can be seen as follows so you
are dividing the input so this thing
start working this point so you divide
the input into two halves so you still
have your to the K bits before now you
have these different groups K different
groups of bits and each group has
through the K divided by K and all you
do is you take the parity of each of the
K groups
you get some bit and then that indexes
into this bit string here so it's a
composition of this multiplexer with
purity okay so a theorem so first shown
when enjoy you have to be in the 2.5
there was a lot of improvement and
optimize by host art shows that this
thing requires a formulas of size about
in cube divided by poly log n I think I
wish I improved the sort of this factor
it's still I mean there's order in cube
size phone as this thing so it's still
like a question of finding something
better for sort of any explicit function
actually better than finish then n cubed
so so the pie log degree increase
decrease by one okay but you don't get
to throw majority on top so our proof of
theorem one is going to mimic aspects of
this basic idea so I will just say at a
very high level how it works so here is
just a reminder of Andres function so as
usual if you use random restrictions you
define some random process on a boolean
function it outputs some boolean
function on a smaller number of inputs
so I like to think about it so you have
some process here are which say randomly
chooses all but a hundred login inputs
to F and sets all the others uniformly
at random so it's it picks some at
random and set some small subset and
this sets all others uniformly and then
you output this small function ok so
it's a very natural kind of way to
restrict a function you want to analyze
kind of what happens to the circuit
complexity of this G depending on what
the function f is
so so the first limo one which I put in
quotes because it's kind of a paraphrase
of what we proof but this is very much
along the lines of how the formula or
bones get proof so first on a
professional threshold circuit C of s
gates if RF were coming from such a
circuit then we can say that this random
process outputs a G so the expected
minimum number of gates in a threshold
threshold is G is strictly less than s
times about 1 over square root of n ok
so we went from s gates to 1 over square
root of n ok in this G now we set a lot
of inputs ok it's a but so this is this
is what we can do there's some sort of
random restriction for threshold
functions in general this kind of low so
the process is expected to output things
with sort of somewhat low Sur complexity
we want to offset that with a limit to
which says in fact with high probability
the thing being output is going to need
at least n over PI log n gate threshold
thresholds ok so and so here it's like
some upper bound on the complexity and
here's a lower bound we just want to
rearrange the inequalities so just to
say a bit about this lemma 2 a little
bit more the idea is that well if you
take a random completely random function
you can show that it will need very high
threshold threshold circuits by Counting
arguments and then the idea is if I'm
applying this to this Andreev function
then each of these parodies is over a
large group ok and the idea is even if
I'm setting like a ton of inputs I want
to say that with high probability for
all of these groups there's something in
there that's left unsaid ok if I can
show that then you know setting all like
almost all these two random this thing
is basically implying the truth table of
some random function sitting in here
right if I leave what each of these like
unset then I can still implement some
hard function some hard random function
on K inputs where K is log in here so
that's that's why that's roughly
speaking why you would get this
Alima - and so combining the one in do
just sort of putting them together you
can show that if a circuit computes this
a then the the size must be at least in
the 1.5 of our plot Williams so it's
just sort of taking this and this and
put it in together so this is the like
any threshold threshold I mean I don't
know a good formula upper bound for
there are threshold like arbitrary
weights yeah it was a good question
actually just in itself what like what
is the form of complexity of that kind
of thing yeah
sorry even just a threshold a single
threshold and I mean it sure it's a
polynomial but how big is a pond we need
to be naive thing I can think of as more
almost like into the four or something
Here I am you know like on the flight so
let me say a little bit more about this
limo one this random restriction think
okay it follows from general random
striction limit here's a weak form of
what we state what we state is actually
former general but this is something
that least give you an idea so FB alt f1
n variables and let K be something much
smaller than in okay so we randomly
choose all but K inputs to F and assign
all the other inputs randomly okay we we
this process let's say I'll put some G
on K variables the probability that G is
a constant function on these remaining K
variables is actually somewhat high it's
at least one minus order K divided by
square root of it so this is like kind
of the the key to thinking about this
and so then having the probability that
you know some gate is a constant
function if it's a constant you could
just remove it in the minimum circuit so
every time something is a constant you
could have just made it smaller so then
the idea is that okay if you set K to be
about a hundred login and you're you're
doing this random assignment on things
the expected number of non constant
gates on this bottom layer is actually
going to be say this this probability so
one minus this thing okay times s the
total number of gates because we this is
a the probability that something does
not become constant okay so so the
expected number of things left over that
are not constant is that all right so so
so far so good that's 15 minutes used up
all right so that's part one all right
so let's take a moment to adjust our
eyes okay
I'm just gonna you know some something
distant like you know so it's not math
okay so they I don't know like I think
if I were reading this talk it would
hurt my isit so okay yeah good
alright now well now we can proceed so
now the second part the talk is how
about probabilistic polynomial for
functions okay again we're looking at
boolean functions but where you can also
think about polynomials over some domain
which is either a finite field or say
the reals in the following so then we
say the distribution on the greedy
polynomials on say D to the end of the D
is some politic polynomial for the
function f of air at most epsilon if for
all inputs to the boolean function but
probably that went a draw a random
polynomial it agrees with the function
on that it is greater than 1 minus
Epsilon
so think if this is just a worst-case
randomized algorithm where your
algorithmic model is the greedy
polynomials so in order to compute on
something you draw a random polynomial
and then with high probability epsilon
and small is giving you the right answer
for that function so people study what
is the kind of optimal air or a degree
trade-off for these kinds of things and
in some cases you can do really well so
a famous example of Roseboro is that the
or function over the field of two
elements has log 1 over Epsilon degree
published eight panels with error
Epsilon ok so just to review that so you
pick some random subset of the varible
indices and you pick up on was just
taking your random some modulo two of
those okay
so definitely this thing is zero when
the when you get all zeros so you know
great error then arrow 0 but it's all to
probably half otherwise okay so this
gives you already a degree one
polynomial with error 1/2 error what
happens maybe not so good so you can
amplify two error epsilon with degree
only order log 1 over epsilon by taking
different uniform random copies of this
thing and composing them like so the
review of policy for animals and how
they work so in this
work with Josh almond and Timothy Chan
we gave some interesting policy panels
related to threshold functions which we
use to prove lower bounce and in fact do
a lot of interesting algorithmic work as
well so first we gave politic funnels
for symmetric functions that don't use
much randomness so particular every
symmetric function boolean symmetric
function on the inputs has a policy
component agree about square root of D
log S an error 1 over s so s is just
some integer parameter using a small
number of renovates the poly log D is
random bits so just to clarify so it was
known the year before that you could in
fact get something with say Omega D
random bits and this matches the old
degree lower bound of rows broth and
Smolinski it was known for many many
years that it's it is square root of the
log S for example for the majority
function it sort of follows from these
canonical or bounds races here with
parity that you get that and it was open
for a very long time if that was
actually optimal so we also give a low
degree polynomial function for Earth of
majority Sao Paulo a threshold function
you can just think of this as a
threshold of ands if you're working over
zero one or a threshold of X or if your
bonds over minus one one and so
essentially what we get is a PT f of
smallest degree just as before so that
for all boolean inputs if so you take
some parameter K could just be anything
between you if if the number of ones and
that thing is less than K the pond will
stay is bounded if it's ever gets at
least K or more it's blows up to like
some s ok so given this kind of thing
you can just take like a sum of s copies
of such a thing and implement an or
function ok so this thing is kind of
winning a majority in fact a threshold
for K for any K thinking of some of them
you can get it or them interestingly we
looked at probabilistic pts so you know
we have politic polynomials you could
have
like panel threshold functions we have a
distribution upon rational functions
trying to compute something and from a
point of view of lower bounds it's not
totally clear what this means but from
the point of view algorithms it's very
interesting if you can get something
better so we in fact get something which
is which sort of breaks this square root
of D degree and gets a cube root of D
degree with with totally similar
properties okay but it's a distribution
of things that are computing this this
function so these two theorems we use
purely algorithmically it's quite
possible they could be used for lower
bounds in some way we use them to design
fast albums for nearest neighbor and the
balloon hypercube approximate nearest
neighbors and they all to norm and and
stuff like that improving over lots of
different results in sort of the log
dimensional case but it is quite
possible these things could be used for
other stuff so I'm gonna say so this
thing in the red box this policy panel
for symmetric functions this is what we
used to get sort of stronger sort of
complexity lower bounds but for like a
not so explicit function so so we
applied that particular policy plural to
get the following applications so first
for some epsilon here
zero for all of them that are depend on
the EPS the depth and modulus under
sufficiently small we can solve the Sat
problem for a cc of threshold of
thresholds faster than exhaustive search
and there's asterisks here and that's
that only applies for circuits that have
say a sub quadratic number of threshold
gates at the bottom but they could have
sub-exponential say to the end to the
order epsilon special tier and such
gates here so I mean so it definitely
gives you a Sat algorithm for
sub-quadratic thresholds of thresholds
but something more general you'd have
like so essential threshold in this
middle part it's not clear but what else
you might compete with that but it's
interesting to know so as a corollary
just kind of applying the known
connections between sours and lower
bounds we get a function in EMP that
doesn't have such circuits okay
so recall that with random restrictions
we got into the 1.5 type lower balance
for gates and here we get sort of up to
quadratic we were bounce for the number
of gates but going beyond that it seems
kind of tricky mainly because of this
square root of the lower bound on the
promised agree for symmetric functions
that I mentioned the previous slide in
fact it holds for the majority function
so so another thing that I want to
mention but I'm not sure what to do with
is that there's a set algorithm for more
complicated circuits so AC zeroes mixed
in with thresholds and randomized faster
than exhaustive search where these
things have slightly greater than linear
fan into the six over five in it and
this uses this probabilistic PTI that
uses almost I think like most of stuff
on the previous slide like in the
different layers to get these three
different layers to work but because
it's randomized we're not quite sure how
to do analyze it and yeah it's not even
it's not totally clear like well we're
bound we would get from that anyway AC 0
there sorry oh yeah
the me orthogonal I should say instead
of stronger yeah you're right it's it's
different yeah definitely yeah yeah
right yes
yeah yeah yeah so yeah it can become
your but I think you could possibly be
Deanna my's like essentially who I used
with the fact was that this policy poem
for sim like up in the first year and we
use the fact that it has it can be done
with low ran this and so you can
actually just enumerate over there and
listen in the circuit itself here I'm
not sure how to do that yeah that's the
main bottleneck so yeah I don't know
what the what corollary to get out of
that mmm
I let me let me say I would like to say
something non-trivial about the white
background part so so here's just a
picture of what the thing that's okay
that's not the non-trivial part so for
so with so sub-quadratic things here is
so like special things here so there's
some things there just to give you a
picture what the thing is so how do we
get this set algorithm well outline at a
high level kind of what the steps are
okay so we we start over here with this
so I said I'll flow to be some parameter
to the for this size versus into the to
minus epsilon for like this size is it's
a sequence of different reductions and
the politic palm oil comes up so we're
in the middle so the first the first
thing is at this point kind of standard
to do with the set algorithm of this
kind you you reduce it to the evaluation
problem over all possible inputs you you
fix some into the Alpha inputs for the
thing you take the or of all possible
assignments to those okay that gives you
again an ACC 0 so I circuit above that
war on top any but it has a fewer inputs
each each of these thresholds here still
have fan-in into the to minus epsilon
but of course like these thresholds like
they're along now and like sort of
different copies for all these different
two to the you know that alpha copies we
had okay so then there's a step where we
use these probabilistic palm oil's for
majority so I said there's these D
randomized politic panels for symmetric
functions
and the key point is that because so we
apply it to these here the key point is
that each of these have so quadratic
number of inputs so whenever I apply my
politic polynomial of square root number
of inputs degree that degree becomes sub
linear and n so like n to the 1 minus
epsilon over 2 degree if they had
constant error now I want more error so
because I want to like do some vote over
all the possible things so that the
blows up the arrow will agree a little
bit here but that's the key point is it
like because I have this square root in
my degree I can handle sub-quadratic LTS
so it looks like this so that over f2
it's just some XOR of ands of like
lowest degree all right now this top
part is still small size it was just
some or before it was just some more of
stuff and now I'm taking some majority
of that stuff and this thing here is
slightly larger just because you know
it's getting close to and because of
this degree here now the idea is you
take this part which is still somewhat
small and replace it with a sin of ants
in this sort of beagle tower
retranslation which is again a kind of
standard thing to do with ACC 0 okay you
do that and then you apply the
distributive law because both of these
ands have like low fanon so this is
actually the smallest fanon it was poly
log in the the size of the thing now
this top sim has a sort of small fan and
still I mean because the
quasi-polynomial they get both of them
here only makes it some larger constant
so then you said you're alpha to be say
order epsilon and you apply these
so-called modulus amplifying polynomials
to this sim on the X or to remove the X
or layer okay so you get something like
this in the vein of threshold and it
turns out that things of this form from
some older work that I had in stock 2014
can be evaluated on all of its possible
assignments in sort of quickly using
sorting tricks and fast matrix multiply
and so you get this kind of set alright
and so you just check if this circuit is
ever outputting one any of its inputs
and if it does if and only if say this
one is
Fievel yeah that's so that's a big
picture all right I just wanted to sort
of show you exactly where the bones get
stuck in and like where they're useful
so open problems so there's lots of nice
open problems here one is tight upper
and lower bounds front draft with
special officials so we have some cubic
threshold threshold circuits from jf I
think you can shave a log factor off
that size but we have only into the 1.5
who are about which is the truth there's
some way to improve their enemy friction
limit or is there a better circuit I
feel like this is something we could
answer another question is very
interesting is whether there are
efficient threshold thresholds for inner
product mod 2 so a negative answer so
showing that's not true would separate
TZ 0 DEP 3 where inner product more 2
can be computed from professional
special another problem which liji is
going to talk about in his talk is how
is getting better sounds for threshold
threshold circuits so this is the state
of the artists is something I talked
about and this is a chin srinivasa and
Santana so they are super linear wires
you can get some some savings over to
the that Delta depends on the epsilon
some way another question is what is the
power or limit of promising polymers
ending boolean functions so you can
think of these as sort of approximate
majorities of threshold of XOR circuits
so if they're very powerful
then you could use them along with FFTs
and matrix multiply to solve a lot of
problems very efficiently break some of
these fine-grained conjectures if
they're limited in some way then you get
some circuit lower bounds for some
interesting class so finally a question
I've been asking many times but I
haven't got an answer yet so four years
ago I gave a fast algorithm that can
evaluate a large threshold of threshold
circuit on all possible inputs very
quickly so polynomial amortize
time for assignment so we will output a
to the N bit string saying what the
value is for this threshold threshold
circuit this should imply a lower bound
right it should not be possible that for
arbitrary circuits of this many gates
you can get such a fast like sort of
evaluation in fact if you could and
things like strong ETH and all that
stuff would be false so this should
imply some lower bound I just don't know
how okay that's all yes Valentin has
some work with also with Daniel Kane
about generalizations of this - pts I
mean so it degrades with a degree as you
would expect in a certain way but yeah
you can you can get lower bounds for
those as well like say constant degree
PDFs of constant ups you can get some
super linear and lower bound based on
what the degrees of those things worth
some trail yes yeah the shrinkage itself
is tight for the majority function
absolutely yeah so instead of looking at
whether it goes to a constant I think I
we talked about this once before instead
of checking whether it goes to constant
whether it goes to just some other
simple function that you could have
gotten rid of for a different reason and
so here were just checking the
probability it's constant but maybe it
could just be like simple no and if it's
some of the words if it's sitting there
there's a way to get rid of it I mean
several things yeah
let's think crying again